[Music]
yeah my book is basically about the
value divide in in modern societies I
focus a lot on Britain but I think a lot
of it applies to America too and I'm
talking about not so much the kind of
elite non-elite divide when we talk
about elites we often mean I think you
know the top three or five percent of
the population I'm talking about a much
bigger divide between the educated and
often mobile people who I call the
anywhere's who tend to value openness
autonomy fluidity they can serve social
change comfortably they tend not to have
strong group attachments they are about
20 25 percent of the population at least
in Britain possibly similar proportions
in America then on the other hand you
have for some ways that they tend to be
about half the population so a bigger
proportion of the population but much
less politically and culturally
influential they tend to be less well
educated they tend to be more rooted to
places that had to value security and
familiarity and they find social change
harder to to serve and they also tend to
have much stronger group attachments
there's also a very useful distinction
that parallels my anywhere somewhere
distinction that comes from the American
sociologist toolkit Parsons talking
about human identity he talks about
people with achieved identities and
ascribed identities we all have a
mixture of the two but anywhere is tend
to have a higher proportion of their
sense of themselves that comes from
their own achievements they passed exams
when they were young they've been to
good universities they have more less
successful professional careers so their
sense of themselves is more kind of
portable they can fit in anywhere
whereas if you are somewhere a bigger
proportion your identity is linked to
particular places and groups and
therefore is more easily discomforted
when those groups or those places change
as a result of immigration or just or
just social change in general so I think
what obviously a lot of a lot of
contemporary analysis is focusing on
this the educated versus the less
educated divide I think what is what is
distinctive about my my look at things
is stressing both how large the the
educated group is and and how dominant
in the in our political system it has
become but also focusing on on two
things that distinguish the the
so-called any words from from the
somewheres one is attitude feelings
about social change on the one hand
relatively positive on the other hand
pretty negative and also feelings about
group attachments or on catchments or on
the case of the anywhere is pretty
pretty weak and in the case of the
somewhere is much stronger and and this
I think has a huge impact on on politics
on divisions so anyways both of right
and left tend to stress a politics of
equality got a more Universalist
equality sort of horizontal politics you
like whereas some ways tend to stress
group attachments and a more kind of
vertical vertical communities if you
like and one thing one must stress here
is that both of these worldviews are
completely legitimate both in a
completely decent at least in their
mainstream variations but the problem
for our politics in in modern liberal
democracies is that these worldviews
conflict in certain fundamental ways
and/or I mean I'm I'm I'm in anywhere
myself IMing Lee and most of those to
people watching this will be anyways but
I think anyways how have over dominated
politics and some ways I felt excluded
and that has created the instability
that has led to brexit in Britain and
and Trump in the United States and I
think we need to take those those
political events as a kind of warning a
kind of fear that kind of early tremor
of what of what might come and we need
to adjust we need to we need to create a
politics in which somewheres feel they
had a louder voice and feel that their
priorities and their intuitions are
taken seriously because I mean I spend
some time in my book just going through
the
Dent the domination of our political and
policy agenda in a country like Britain
I think it applies to America too of
anywhere priorities if you look at
everything from the economy to education
policy to family policy to attitude to
social mobility and niche in the
achievement society it we have created
societies in which cognitive ability has
become the kind of gold standard of
human esteem human measurement and a lot
of people but by definition half the
population are always going to be in the
bottom half of the cognitive ability
spectrum but even people who are not in
the bottom half of the cognitive ability
spectrum I think often feel rather
alienated by a society dominated by
cognitive elites who perhaps feel less
less attachment to duty to non elite
than they are less paternalistic than
the previous generations of elites yeah
I think one of the interesting questions
is why is this happening now I mean on
the face of it you might say that the
society has always been divided to some
extent between the highly educated and
mobile people with perhaps more more
open minds and and more rooted people
with more more skepticism about the
outside world but why why is this why is
this now risen to such an important
place in our politic I think there are
two reasons for that
one is that and this is particularly
true I think of Britain in Europe one is
that the the framework of politics until
quite recently has been essentially
socio-economic it's been the key blocks
have been social classes the issues have
been about size of the state attitudes
to equality and inequality these have
been the themes that have dominated
British and European politics in the
last generation or so you've seen the
emergence of what one might call
socio-cultural politics politics that
stresses issues of security and identity
and that's relatively new in Europe it's
perhaps not so new in America religion
and races always played a bigger role in
American politics and it has in in
Europe at least recently so I think
you've seen socio-cultural politics in
merging to kind of challenge that the
traditional dominance of socio-economic
issues and that is in itself partly a
reaction to the much greater openness of
our economies and our cultures over the
last 20 or 30 years it's a kind of it's
a it's a reaction against that openness
that you've seen the socio-cultural
politics
emerging so strongly and the second
reason is that the is simply that the
number of anyways has grown quite
dramatically I mean you just go back 50
or 60 years American common sense was
essentially somewhere common sense
British common sense was essentially
some work on sense it is now in the
public realm almost entirely
anyway common sense you know what it is
to lead a good life and achieved life is
about being in anyway it's about leaving
often about leaving your hometown going
to a good university becoming a member
of the kind of upper professional class
have been of being part of that
cognitive elite and it's kind of
logically impossible and so everybody
can do that
not everybody can join the upper
professional class and I think we've
we've kind of eroded the stories for for
people who are not part of that that
successful achieved group and you see it
also in the way in which you know you
know we talk about the knowledge economy
I mean a knowledge economy by definition
is one that that is beneficial to the
highly qualified at the same time as
we've seen the emergence of the
knowledge economy we've also seen the
disappearance of so many of those
middling jobs that used to give people's
status and protection and somebody said
to me the other day I sure didn't write
this in the book but it's something I've
learnt talking about the book is
somebody who used to be a manual worker
said that so many jobs used to used to
require not a huge amount of cognitive
ability but a lot of
experience to do well and that I think
applies particularly to the kind of
skilled manual manufacturing jobs that
we've lost lost in so many of and that
and jobs that you couldn't just walk in
off the street you know as a kind of
successful Harvard graduate or whatever
and do that job there was there was
protection to your status for the fact
that it required a lot of experience to
do well and and I think we've seen that
kind of replicate we've seen the kind of
draining away this is so much more I
think about you know this is labor not
Marx and this is so much more about it's
used to do with status and recognition
and what one might call it sounds rather
old-fashioned one one might call social
honor that people used to feel they had
doing ordinary middling things that they
no longer feel they have they feel that
because of status it's not just if now
we've also had stagnant wages
particularly America for a generation or
more exacerbated obviously by the by the
financial crash but into not certainly
in Britain and Europe I don't exist
primarily in economic issues it's much
more cultural issue much more to do with
status and recognition obviously the two
things very very tightly wound up
together in many cases rather hard to
disentangle
you